it's had a great reputation and if it
was somebody else other than me people
would say gee isn't that smart but we
are working on a lot of other things we
have I'll tell you I the great medical
companies that we have if you look at
what they're doing therapeutically pure
wise and the vaccine itself and the
vaccine I think is less important than
some of the things they're working on
they're working on a cure and we have
more than one doing it and very advanced
they're working on therapeutics and
they're working on vaccine tremenda
there's been tremendous brilli
tremendous progress yeah they have a lot
of use advisor I didn't get involved I
purposely said to Mitch you go do what
you want we'll take a look we're gonna
look at Pfizer but nobody's been abused
by Pfizer like the President of the
United States because what the Democrats
did and the dirty cops their dirty cops
the FBI people are great of it you go in
there they like Donald Trump but the top
of the FBI they were dirty cops they
were crooked bad people and nobody's
been abused more than Trump but you look
at general Flynn you look at so many
others not just that not just us take a
look at so many others look at what
they've done how they've abuse lies so
I'm going to be studying it very much
but the Pfizer process has gone awry it
was used by very dishonest people it was
used illegally and frankly the judges of
the FISA Court should do something about
it and maybe they will well I think on
the swing stages on the Flynn case
general Flynn is a man of great respect
I was with general Milley the head of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff the other day
I said you know general Flynn he said
yes I do he's a fine man I've known him
for 20 years he's a fine man and a great
soldier general Flynn was treated
horribly general Flynn was treated
illegally these people they broke the
law they broke the law what they've done
to general Flynn should never happen
what they've done to the presidency and
what they
done to this country can never be
allowed to happen again to our country
and despite all of that has been done
everything that's been done we've had
one of the greatest presidencies ever we
have never I don't think anybody Mitch I
think we can say it with the surety
nobody's accomplished what we've
accomplished in a relatively short
period of time a 3-year period of time
nobody's been able to do that when you
look at rebuilding our military
regulations at a level that nobody's
come close to we've cut regulations the
biggest tax decrease in history you look
at all of the things that we've done all
of the things we've done on health care
with the individual mandate with
pre-existing conditions nobody's done
anywhere close to what we've done but
despite that if you look despite and a
legal witch-hunt and that's what it was
it was a hoax it was a witch hunt the
Russian thing was a made-up fabricated
story just like they went to
congresswoman Kelsey Gabbard I don't
know her at all and they said you're a
Russian agent I don't know her but I
know she's not a Russian agent then they
went to dr. Jill Stein of the Green
Party they said she's a Russian agent I
don't know her at all I know she's not a
Russian agent these people are sick
Pelosi is a sick woman it's got a lot of
problems a lot of mental problems we're
dealing with people that have to get
their act together for the good of the
country okay thank you
[Laughter]
welcome back